I feel like this could give someone
what's that like the trick trophobia or
when when the little the porous things
so it's a crumpet a crumpet
oh wow I've heard of crumpets like tea
and crumpets and I I know this was The
Crumpet do people buy this in the store
yeah you need yeah you need to really
toast it cuz otherwise it's is this
toasted it doesn't feel to feels it
honestly it looks and it feels like a
sponge like that would clean like the
toilet with
[Music]
guys doesn't taste like
anything with no taste
whatsoever you put jam on it or the
holes to fill with Jam yeah you can put
jam on
it don't even try don't I'm not doing
that